it's like rick takes porn yeah can you  play these kind of desperados okay he's  done it he's actually played it and he  can give up his rook black because the  white rook is under fire from the black  knight so rather than go for a direct  trade you might as well try and grab a  pawn in the process and magnus look at  him he is furious he's about to be a  pawn down  it should be a draw because everything's  just disappearing from me  but he needs to move that's right and  huge time trouble for both of them there  could definitely be some blunders here  definitely and magnus is i think he's  blunted a couple of times already uh  he's lucky he's not losing on the spot  but look at this magnus is going to have  to defend a difficult end game because  he's lost his knight magnus has lost his  knight but he will be able to remove  black's remaining pawn from the position  and he's so frustrated